welcome back to CBS this morning the
family of a soldier who vanished from
Fort Hood in Texas more than two months
ago is demanding answers
twenty-year-old private first class
Vanessa Guillen was last seen in April
the Army's Criminal Investigation
Command is looking into her
disappearance army investigators say
they suspect foul play
in recent weeks protesters have gathered
at Fort Hood and Indians hometown of
Killeen to rally behind her family
Mireya Villarreal spoke with the
family's attorney Maria does the family
trust that the Army is actually looking
out for them in this we know good
morning Anthony right now the family
feels Fort Hood officials are not doing
enough to find Vanessa G and they do not
trust army investigators and they're
actually asking congressional lawmakers
to step in and put the FBI or another
federal agency in charge they are headed
to Washington DC as we speak
and they want to meet with members of
Congress about this case they're not
here to help us find Vanessa they're
here to work that information because
they don't want us know what's happened
Ian's family attorney Natalie Cohen is
demanding the army release more
information about private first class
Vanessa Gaines disappearance you believe
that they are the bases withholding
information from the Ian family they're
covering up for each other
Guillen was last seen on April 22nd
wearing a black t-shirt and purple
workout pants her car keys wallet and ID
were found in the armory room on base
where she was working that morning but
her phone is missing Ian's family
believes someone Vanessa knew is
responsible was Vanessa having problems
with in her unit well we understand that
she was sexually harassed by a couple of
her superiors at two different occasions
that she reported to her family her
friends and her colleagues at work lupa
Guillen is her sister she was
which is unacceptable because she was
supposed to be saved while working in
protecting the country we live in Fort
Hood has launched an investigation into
the allegations that Gihon was sexually
harassed so far army investigators say
they have no credible reports that
Vanessa Guillen was sexually assaulted
since Guillen went missing volunteers in
the FBI are assisting army investigators
they have scoured fields at a river near
the base army investigators say they are
doing everything in their power to find
her we won't stop this effort until
we're successful and with your help we
can be successful sooner Domingo Garcia
is the national president of LULAC the
League of United Latin American citizens
the Guillen family reached out to the
organization for help not giving the
answers to the family 30 days after her
disappearance
and we decided would he just start great
pressure to find out what happened to
business you see what was easy in a
recent press conference Vanessa's mother
Gloria Guillen gave an emotional plea
for justice for her daughter who wanted
to join the army since she was 10 years
old if she comes up dead
close this base she said Guillen is the
second soldier to go missing at Fort
Hood in recent months Gregory Weddell
Morales disappeared last August his
remains were found 11 days ago the army
is still investigating but foul play is
suspected there's eyes and ears
everywhere on a base so whatever is
going on in that base needs to be
investigated we need to find out because
nobody's safe on that base nobody's safe
right now in the military
Vanessa Guillen story has launched a
social media movement with people using
the hashtag I am Vanessa I am Vanessa
Guillen hundreds of service members have
posted their own stories of sexual
assault or sexual harassment online I
have spoken with several of them last
fiscal year there was a three percent
rise in the number of sexual assault
cases reported throughout the entire
military Gail
Mireya that story is so disturbing I
hope it won't take long for the family
to get answers
seems like authorities have a lot of
clues to work with do they you know
right now it sounds like they are
ramping up their investigation so the
family is hopeful but they also that
hope is tempered right now because it's
taken so long to get through this point
they do believe social media and just a
lot of activism has really played a part
in trying to get this thing moving a
very upsetting story thank you very much
Maria